2021 was full of bangers and 2022 looks
to be no different let's jump in with
the 20 biggest games coming in 2022
the long-awaited sequel to gorillaz hit
game horizon zero dawn was planned to
release in 2021 but is now arriving
early 2022 given the high bar set by its
predecessor that might be for the best
horizon forbidden west as the name
suggests sees aeloy venturing into the
western united states as she continues
her journey of survival and discovery in
a post-apocalyptic world overrun by
dinosaur-like robots stealth acrobatic
traversal and bow combat are at the
heart of the franchise and all look to
be making their return in full force for
the sequel we'll also likely get some
more answers regarding some of the
game's more intriguing sci-fi questions
five years is a long time to wait
bethesda game studios first new ip in 25
years is coming in november 2022 and we
are very very excited about it after
making a name for itself with fantasy
games bethesda is turning its attention
to the sci-fi genre with starfield an
rpg about the appeal of exploring the
great unknown art director matt carafano
said recently it's got a more realistic
science-based backing to it whereas
skyrim is sort of an epic fantasy this
is a more grounded game and a grounded
setting about exploration so i think
that gives us a different take on how we
make everything
after enjoying great ongoing success
with rainbow six siege ubisoft is
returning to the tom clancy series with
a new game rainbow six extraction due
for release in january the game includes
a number of features and elements from
siege however ubisoft maintains that
siege and extraction are different
enough to appeal to different audiences
in extraction players team up to fight
against alien enemies for example
extraction is a budget priced game
coming in at 40 dollars and includes
buddy pass tokens that you can give to
friends that allow them to play as much
as they want at no cost for two weeks
rocksteady the uk studio that made the
batman arkham games is returning with
suicide squad kill the justice league
it's the studio's first new game since
2015's arkham knight in 2016's arkham
knight vr so we're excited to finally
play a new game from them the game
features members of the suicide squad
you may remember from the films and
comics including harley quinn deadshot
boomerang and king shark a one to four
player co-op game that killed the
justice league puts players on a mission
to
kill the justice league intriguingly
rocksteady sefton hill has said some of
the narrative threads from the arkham
trilogy will carry forward to the new
game but the specifics are unclear
borderlands developer gearbox is making
a spin-off of sorts called tiny tina's
wonderlands the game features the voices
of very funny people like andy sandberg
wanda sykes will annette and ashley
burch returns to voice tiny tina herself
the game is described as an epic high
fantasy take on the looter shooter genre
that gearbox itself pioneered with
borderlands players will shoot slash and
cast magical spells to try and take down
the evil dragon lord the game also
supports co-op for up to four players
and end game content that is replayable
the witch is back bayonetta 3 seems to
have been in development forever but in
2021 we finally got a look at some
gameplay bayonet is known for some of
the most deliriously camp action-shooter
gameplay out there and the eponymous
character is as charming as she is
deadly defeating hordes of angels and
demons with flowing locks of hair that
would make rapunzel jealous we can't
wait to play the third installment in
this series
square enix is making a final fantasy
prequel game called stranger of paradise
final fantasy origin and it's one of our
most anticipated upcoming games
developed by team ninja stranger of
paradise appears to adopt more of a
neo-like gameplay formula into the final
fantasy dynamic according to square enix
stranger of paradise will feel different
from previous final fantasy games but
still has quote the blood of final
fantasy running through its veins the
game features real-time combat and
players can take on a variety of jobs as
they use magic and physical attacks team
ninja has a style and reputation of its
own from the ninja gaiden series and
we're excited to see how those skills
and sensibilities are applied to final
fantasy
redfall the next game from arcane
studios creators of the dishonored
series and death loop looks to be quite
a big departure the cooperative first
person shooter which is coming in summer
2022 tasks you and your friends to
destroy the vampire plague that has
overrun the titular town it allows for
single-player gameplay as well and
arcane promises that it retains the
studio's signature level design to help
it stand out from other cooperative
shooters with character customization
and special abilities alongside vampires
human enemies dedicated to worshiping
them will also stand in your way and
hopefully your bullets way
the original dying light from techland
was a spectacular blend of parkour-based
traversal and hack and slash gameplay
wrapped up within the drama of the
zombie apocalypse it was essentially a
more realized version of the developer's
previous efforts with dead island and it
succeeded with showcasing an ambitious
sense of scope and brutality while
barreling through the ruined streets of
haran dying light 2 continues with many
of the original's key strengths from
free-form traversal melee combat and
overwhelming encounters with the undead
while the sequel aims to go bigger
featuring a map that greatly dwarfs the
originals the most significant change is
its approach to narrative in dying light
2 your actions can irreparably alter the
course of the larger story and even
change the layout of the world itself by
bringing together the free form
traversal and combat with an rpg style
narrative dying light 2 is already
shaping up to be a massive step up from
the original that will ensure your
actions leave a significant impression
on the world
since the release of demon souls way
back in 2009 developer from software has
significantly redefined itself moving
away from niche status to a real aaa
force within the games industry their
signature high risk high reward gameplay
has seen many imitators over the years
debuting at e3 2019 the cryptic trailer
for elden ring showed off a world in
conflict while not unfamiliar to the
visuals and plot of the dark souls
trilogy the scale of elden ring is
significantly larger and moves more
towards the iconography of norse
mythology eldon ring brings in many of
the familiar elements of a souls game
but with an increased focus on world
building as it turns out a song of ice
and fire creator george r.r martin which
became the hbo series game of thrones
you might have heard of it has
collaborated with from software on the
overarching narrative of the game with
an open world setting realized by
martin's writing designed around from
software's gameplay eldon ring could be
yet another big step forward for the
developer and potentially for the
infamous subgenre as well
how do you follow up one of the greatest
games of all time of course make a
direct sequel which we don't know the
official title of just yet has us all
clamoring for details with recent
trailer footage offering a tantalizing
glimpse into the setting we'll be
exploring hopefully in the near future
we've all been speculating as to what
the next hyrule adventure will entail
with folks even going over the symbolism
used in an effort to decipher what the
zelda team has in store combine this
with the potential narrative
implications of the recent spin-off
hyrule warriors age of calamity there
are any number of scenarios that could
play out breath of the wild was so
brilliant in part because of its
wondrous sense of discovery and
exploration its sequel will take to the
skies in an exciting attempt to reach
the same dizzying heights hopefully in
2022 on nintendo switch
a brand new action adventure game from
square enix for spoken c's protagonist
frey holland transported from our world
into a fantasy realm called atheia where
she's given the power to soar through
the air and cast magical spells it looks
like a cross between the movement in a
game like marvel spider-man with a much
more magical move set and given the
fidelity of the trailers and the high
speed action we've seen thus far it
makes sense that the game will only be
available on ps5 and pc but square enix
is certainly hoping for the game to be
more than a tech demo for the system as
is the new internal studio luminous
productions
ghostwire tokyo is one of the most
exciting upcoming games for ps5 as it's
a completely new experience for studio
tango gameworks the company is now owned
by microsoft but honoring an earlier
timed exclusivity agreement ghostwire is
not a survival horror game instead it's
a paranormal action adventure with
spooky elements that's played from a
first first-person perspective
with a combat flow that resembles
something like dishonored it remains to
be seen if that combat can mesh with
investigating supernatural occurrences
but tango gameworks has a knack for
world building and has already shown
great improvement since the original
evil within
the 2018 soft reboot for god of war
which continued the story but radically
overhauled the gameplay was one of the
best ps4 games sony santa monica studio
is certainly looking to match that
quality with god of war ragnarok a game
that will wrap up the norse storyline
we've only seen a glimpse of gameplay
thus far and kratos's son atreus will
play a major role once again will kratos
be able to defeat thor the god of
thunder or will the once disgraced
demigod finally be destroyed
well probably not but we won't know for
sure until the game releases which will
hopefully be in 2022
the advance wars series brought some of
the best tactical gameplay of the game
boy advance and nintendo ds era now we
get to revisit it with a fresh new look
in the form of advance wars 1 and 2
reboot camp a nintendo switch remake of
the first two games featuring turn-based
gameplay on a grid the advance wars
games see you assume the role of one of
the various commanding officers
directing troops to victory with each
military group capable of using
game-changing special abilities such as
unit repairs or power boosts
who's going to protect gotham city
without batman around batgirl nightwing
red hood and robin of course and in an
open world action rpg called gotham
knights no less the game can be played
solo or in two-player co-op with what's
said to be a seamless drop in and out
system the story will be separate from
the existing batman arkham series though
gotham night's main story will be about
the rise of the bat family following
batman's apparent death and their
conflict with the gotham city rogues
gallery which includes the infamous
court of owls
after remaining dormant since lego star
wars the force awakens in 2016 tt games
is coming back to the franchise that
started its wildly successful
kid-friendly series with a soft reboot
lego star wars the skywalker saga will
encompass all nine numbered star wars
films making for the first time the
games have explored the most recent two
the last jedi and rise of skywalker but
these are more than remasters instead tt
games is starting fresh by rethinking
the entire mechanical foundation of lego
star wars and making new cutscenes to
modernize the long-standing action
platformer the release date has slipped
a few times and it's currently due in
early 2022
after making a name for itself with the
x-com series developer for axis games is
making a marvel game next with midnight
sons the tactical turn-based game
features famous marvel characters like
iron man captain america doctor strange
captain marvel and wolverine it appears
midnight suns borrows from the fire
emblem series with players able to build
relationships as they take on the role
of a new marvel hero named the hunter
players use ability cards on each turn
and work together with teammates to take
down enemies
pokemon legends archaeas is shaping up
to be one of the most exciting new
additions to the series in years where
pokemon sword and shield took small
steps into open world exploration with
the wild area pokemon legends archaeas
looks to be going all in set in the
distant past you play as an adventurer
tasked with creating the sinner region's
first pokedex in a significant change to
the series arceus appears to take place
in real time with catching pokemon
requiring you to aim and throw pokeballs
while they roam openly in the wild its
lush nature filled open world setting
has drawn comparisons to the legend of
zelda breath of the wild a game that
certainly makes for good inspiration the
focus on the eponymous pokemon promises
plenty of interesting narrative
implications as archaeas is considered a
deity-like figure that created the
sinner region we'll find out more when
arceus hits nintendo's switch in january
splatoon the family-friendly ink shooter
is a big seller for nintendo so the
announcement of splatoon 3 was a welcome
inevitability the splatoon series has
captured imaginations worldwide with its
bright and fast-paced gameplay fresh
music and the hotly contested splatfests
splatoon 3 setting as shown in the
reveal trailer is a mad max style desert
wasteland which looks moody as hell and
looks like a fascinating location for
waging turf wars one of the new weapons
revealed is a bow capable of shooting
ink arrows to take out opposition
inklings and claim territory for your
team both splatoon games released so far
have been brilliant fun for all ages
which is exactly what we're expecting
when splatoon 3 splashes onto switch
sometime in 2022
so there you have it our most
anticipated games of 2022 we'll always
have all the latest so make sure you
like this video and subscribe thanks so
much for watching have a good one
[Music]